What is H. Pylori? And how do you treat it?
We've talked about H. Pylori on our holistic health tower a lot.
I have some I think good videos on our website too and
User website is a resource cutters clinic.com. It can be helpful. You can search for all sorts of things on there and
What is H. Pylori? So H. Pylori is short for helico back to Pylori. It's a bacteria
Gram-negative bacteria that normally is a part of your normal gut flora in balance, but it can become out of balance and
Opportunistically take over quite quickly.
It is the number one bacterial infection worldwide according to the World Health Organization.
It's the number one cause of stomach cancer. It's the cause of stomach ulcers
But it can cause other things as well. I mentioned earlier that it is a major cause of endothelial disorders and endothelial disease, high blood pressure,
you know myocardial imparction, etc.
It could be a cause of other cancers and
It is preventable. So it's usually it's the opportunity for it to flourish
tends to stem
Primarily from hypochlorhendria. So when people have a decreased stomach acid production
Then they end up with H. Pylori starting to flourish in the stomach and then it spreads from there to other organs and into the
intestines and
Systemically it could cause an array of problems. So
You want to get that in order the worst thing that people do is they go on a PPI or take Tubs or something like that
Probably one of the worst drugs ever created because it just if somebody's out at PPI
It's pretty much guaranteed. You've got H. Pylori just hands down. You don't even take the test support
Everybody should treat as if they have H. Pylori on a regular basis and your number one treatment for H. Pylori is make sure you're get your stomach acid back into balance support your digestion by taking H. C. L
with digestive enzymes and take a H. Pylori type supplement. You're one of the best things is garlic and burberry to kill H. Pylori
That is my favorite. So that's why one of my favorite
Nutritional supplements on the planet is burberry because it is a great killer of H. Pylori
It can be a killer of cancer and a whole bunch of different things. So if you want more information on H. Pylori
How to deal with it. How to understand
Hypochloridria, which is a decreased stomach acid go to our website search hypochloridria search H. Pylori and I think there's multiple blog posts that look back and forth and give you
Details on how to help yourself with that